it's on April 22nd 2012 people looked up
and saw giant fireball streaking across
the sky over California and Nevada
even though meteors fall at all times of
the day and night it's rare to see one
during the day and it's also rare for
meteor create a sonic boom that
reportedly was loud enough to set off
car alarms and rattle people's windows
the amount of information they were able
to gather about this meteor was pretty
unprecedented Doppler weather radar
picked it up in Reno and Sacramento the
sonic boom was recorded as far away as
Washington State and people also snapped
pictures of the meteor fireball with
their cameras as they were walking their
dogs so using all of these sources
scientists were able to determine how
fast the meteor was traveling as it
entered the atmosphere and its size so
between two to four meters in diameter
between 20 to 80 metric tons then they
narrowed down where they should search
for the fragments and that was centered
around Sutter's Mill California near the
town of Coloma where coincidentally gold
was discovered in the 19th century so in
sort of a repeat of the California Gold
Rush
you had locals meteorite hunters
scientists rush onto the scene to search
for meteorites scientists from NASA and
said he arrived many people actually
opened up their homes or land to let
them search the scientists went up in a
Zeppelin to take the lay of the land and
look for evidence of crater impact so
maybe a hole in a roof or place where
branches got broken and after about two
months they'd found 74 pieces which
added up to about two pounds they were
in a huge rush to pick up the chunks of
meteorite because water can change the
natural chemistry of the rocks from what
they found they were able to determine
that these are an unusual type of
meteorite called carbonaceous chondrites
carbonaceous chondrites have clues about
the early solar system and possibly even
origins of life it is a witty
special meat right because this
particular one contains all the goodies
that scientists are interested in the
amino acids all the compounds that could
have made life possible on our planet
this new paper in science tells us that
the meteorite is quite complex in terms
of its geophysics and its geochemistry
it also contains some very rare very
reactive minerals and is quite young
compared to most other meteorites and
it's family so what's exciting about
this others no meteorite to me is how it
shows how scientists and communities can
work together hopefully as technology
improves and as more people are looking
for these sorts of things coming out of
the sky we'll get a better sense of how
life originated in our solar system
you